why did the u.s go to war in iraq we're
in the early stages of military
operations
growing up the narrative was always oil
so it's like we went to iraq to get oil
like america always does
we might find ourselves without adequate
supplies of energy in the future
all major oil fields in the south are
now under coalition control but that's
kind of the lazy explanation it's not
quite it oil's a part of it but it's not
the main reason
we went to war in iraq because several
powerful american men wanted to some of
them thought
it was vital we had to others just
wanted to project
american power but either way here we
are 18 years later
nearly 10 000 americans dead over 200
000
iraqis dead over a trillion tax dollars
spent
and the result a middle east that is
less stable than ever
in part because of the u.s presence and
really because of it
how did this happen i mean i grew up and
lived through
this i studied it as an undergrad i
studied it in grad school
and yet it's taken me until now to
really take a hard look
and to really understand exactly what
happened so this
is how the us stole iraq saddam hussein
is a tyrant
a murderer and a man who has started to
wars he is clearly someone
who cannot be trusted or believed
all right so it's the night of 9 11 the
country is reeling
who did this terrible thing and why how
should the u.s
respond and it became clear very soon
amongst intelligence and
counter-terrorism people that
al qaeda was behind it this terrorist
group that was mainly based in
afghanistan later that night the night
of 9 11
over at the pentagon which earlier that
day had been
hit by an airplane a memo comes in from
the deputy secretary of state
the memo is urgent it's for the defense
intelligence agency the people who spend
their time doing all the intelligence
for war and other defense purposes and
this memo
tells the intelligence agents not to
look into al qaeda the people they
know did it but instead to look into
ways
iraq has been involved in terrorism for
the previous decade the intelligence
agents who got this memo sort of
scratched their head
and were like wait what what's going on
here these people were very familiar
with the intel
and they knew that this attack had come
from al qaeda in afghanistan
afghanistan is like more than a thousand
kilometers away from iraq it is a
completely different place they speak a
different language it has nothing to do
with iraq afghanistan and iraq are
totally different
we had just been attacked by al qaeda
and yet
the deputy secretary of defense is
asking for
information about iraq and its ties to
terrorism
the person who sent this memo was the
deputy secretary of state
paul wolfowitz and he was just getting
started
[Music]
a few days after 9 11 the president
gathers all of his top advisors
out at his forest retreat right outside
of washington dc
they were there to discuss how to
respond to these attacks
the focus of this discussion was of
course afghanistan how do we retaliate
against al qaeda
this terrorist group that has been given
sort of a safe haven by the government
of afghanistan so they're sitting in
some conference room in some
lodge in this forest retreat debating
how they're going to retaliate against
al qaeda and who pipes up again
but this guy paul wolfowitz this time
with the support of his boss
secretary of defense donald rumsfeld so
wolfowitz pipes up and he's like
you know 911 was a pretty sophisticated
attack there's no way that this ragtag
terror group of al-qaeda could have
pulled it off all alone
they probably had help from saddam in
iraq and then wolfowitz says that when
it comes to global terrorism
saddam is actually the head of the snake
he actually said that
basically saying that saddam is behind
all of this
and everyone in the room is sort of like
um what the hell is this guy
talking about saddam hussein is a really
bad guy
but he's not the head of the snake of
international terrorism
like all these people these like very
informed international
like advisors oh man
after some astonished glances the head
of the counterterrorism center
raises his hands and says mr president
quote we were attacked on 9 11 by osama
bin laden and al qaeda
in afghanistan saddam hussein in iraq
has nothing to do with this it's just
like
i i'm sorry i feel like as an eighth
grader
at this time i was asking these
questions i was like is iraq the same as
afghanistan
and here here are like the leaders of
our country having to explain
that like saddam hussein has nothing to
do with afghanistan and al qaeda so this
meeting
at camp david they move on and they keep
talking about these plans to bomb
al qaeda but paul wolfowitz is stubborn
and he does not give up later that day
there's a break in all of the meetings
it's like the afternoon
attorney general john ashcroft is
playing the piano in the sort of
lobby and a few others were singing
along the
these like piano spirituals that he's
playing condoleezza rice is one of these
people singing along
president bush is sitting over by the
fire it's like this rustic cabin it's
all cozy he's drinking a cup of coffee
and who cozies up to him at the fire
but paul wolfowitz and bush is like
ugh here we go again so he's like listen
check out my plan
half of iraq's people live either way up
here where they don't like saddam
they're kurds they've been
brutalized by saddam they do not like
them or they live way down here in the
south
which is right near the border of our
good friend kuwait
we could easily come into iraq and take
both of these big population centers
oh and in doing so says paul wolfowitz
we could naturally take the major oil
fields in iraq
thus cutting off saddam from his main
revenue source or
in other words he said making saddam
quote the mayor of baghdad he would only
have power in baghdad
he would be cut off from the north and
south of his country in this moment i
can almost see
george bush's ears like literally
perking up when he hears this last part
about cutting off
the oil supply after all bush was a
former texas oil man
and he knew the importance of having
access to oil so this plan sort of
intrigued bush
and he literally said to paul wolfowitz
quote why didn't you bring this
up in the meeting and wolf woods is like
well i didn't want to like step on the
toes of my superiors and wolfowitz we
know you just wanted to cozy up against
the president and plant the seed
of how easy it would be to take over
iraq
so put yourself in george bush's shoes
for a second
your country was just brutally attacked
on your watch
and you are completely at a loss of what
to do there's no clear easy target to
retaliate against
after a day of meetings of sitting
around trying to figure out how to
retaliate
george bush is realizing that
retaliating against
a tiny group of terrorists living in
caves in afghanistan
is like trying to hit smoke with a
baseball bat
kind of impossible what george bush
wanted and felt like he needed and
it turns out what a lot of american
lawmakers also wanted
was a clear decisive target not to try
to hit smoke with a baseball bat but a
nice
solid hit a home run so i believe
this day at camp david four days after 9
11
is when president bush decided that he
would find
a way to invade iraq to make americans
and himself
feel like he was actually doing
something definitive
like toppling dictators as a rebuttal to
the terrible attacks of 9 11.
even though iraq had nothing to do with
al qaeda he and his people around him
would find
a way to make a connection
if they're harboring terrorists why not
go in and get them well the
evidence is pretty conclusive that the
iraqis have indeed harbored tariffs
so over the next year this seed that
paul wolfowitz
really planted and nourished in george
bush's mind starts to spread
to everyone around him and they start to
find a way
to sell the american public on this idea
of war with iraq they get the british on
board
and soon there's a full-blown debate
which revolves around this story
that saddam has really big terrible
weapons
and that he will likely give those
weapons to terrorists who will strike
the united states in another 9 11
type attack but way worse the debate
about the war against iraq has divided
many along the political spectrum
real concern about this russian award
kept saying weapons of mass destruction
over and over again
he learned that short phrase very
dangerous weapons of mass destruction
into this country but wait hold on a
second don't be fooled
the lead-up to the iraq war is often
remembered as this
robust debate about wmds weapons of mass
destruction
saddam hussein will continue to increase
his capacity to wage biological and
chemical warfare
and will keep trying to develop nuclear
weapons
but i'm here to tell you that you need
to think differently about it the
decision to go to war in iraq was
already made
it was made moments after 9 11 when a
small group of powerful men
imagined a glorious military campaign to
liberate
oppressed iraqis and topple a dictator
to make themselves
and their country feel like we got a
home run after we were attacked from
there
everything molded to fit that decision
did saddam hussein have weapons of mass
destruction did he want to give those to
terrorists
no there was no evidence the little
evidence there was was
threadbare and super speculative but
these guys turned into
sort of like tea leaf readers where you
could look at the tea leafs
and see whatever you need to to support
the decision that they made
many months earlier and it wasn't just
these guys soon this vision
of toppling saddam and having this
american victory spread to the american
congress republicans and democrats who
are also getting on board with this idea
of
america a force for good toppling the
bad guy
it's a really wild study in human
psychology
when you're a true believer in something
you really really believe that you need
to do something
everything you see confirms what you
want to believe
or what you need to believe we all do it
but it's just scary when
our leaders are doing this and they're
doing it on
beliefs and decisions that have deep
ramifications for human suffering
so yeah you can go over the debates and
the intelligence and the back and forth
on whether or not saddam had weapons of
mass destruction
it was all a show to help these people
confirm what they already decided
they wanted to do so by the end after
weapons inspectors had done like
700 inspections and found no weapons
this group of guys eventually just
start resorting to full lying dick
cheney gets up
in a speech and says simply stated there
is no doubt
that saddam hussein now has weapons of
mass destruction
well there was plenty of doubt in fact
he simply stated
there can be no evidence that saddam has
wmd
was the reality at the time even the
secretary of state
colin powell who was totally against
this
fantasiful vision of going and invading
iraq even him
eventually got on board painstakingly
getting in front of the un
and going over a bunch of thin or
non-existent evidence
and claiming that it was watertight my
colleagues
every statement i make today is backed
up by sources
solid sources these are not assertions
what we're giving you are facts and
conclusions based
on solid intelligence solid intelligence
no no no
these are words that colin powell has
lived to regret for the rest of his life
a lot of people saw colin powell as like
the one sane guy in the room
and so here at the u.n when he's
drinking the kool-aid and
backing this intelligence a lot of
people got on board by october 10th
2002 the us congress was fully on board
almost all the republicans in the
chamber as well as a sizable group of
democrats voted to authorize the u.s to
use
force against iraq senate joint
resolution 45 to authorize the use of
united states armed forces against iraq
he has said he wants the power to be
able to go to war it seems completely
consistent
with that request that we say yes mr
president you have that power to go to
war this resolution
gives president the authority he needs
to confront the threat
posed by iraq saddam hussein and his
sons
must leave iraq within 48 hours and then
it happened sirens went off in baghdad
just a few minutes ago
an air raid is in progress over baghdad
explosions
in baghdad our nation enters this
conflict
surrendered reluctantly the border
two months after the invasion george
bush gives a speech
on an aircraft carrier with this giant
sign that says
quote mission accomplished this is the
type of thing
bush surely was dreaming about while he
was sitting by the fire
at camp david drinking coffee listening
to paul wolfowitz explain the plan to
take over iraq
big triumphant america just toppled the
dictator
mission accomplished but this is the
part of the story when all of the dreams
the fantasies the visions of glory
start to topple mission accomplished was
really
mission just beginning
one of the first things that the us did
when they took over baghdad
was they dissolved the huge iraqi
military they just said
no we don't want you anymore all of you
commanders and leaders
soldiers you're out we're going to start
fresh in typical simplistic thinking of
these visionary leaders
the idea was that doing so would allow
them to start totally fresh
with a new army completely rid of any
sort of influence of saddam hussein so
now you have a bunch of ex-iraqi
army members who are angry at the united
states and
unemployed oh and all of them have
extensive
military experience there is a large
number of
former iraqi soldiers that are
unemployed now
that is a huge concern it is just
painful what a terrible decision so
these guys run off
and they start to join the growing
number
of rebel groups that are there cropping
up to oppose the united
states presence one of those groups is
called al qaeda in iraq
which later turns into the islamic state
of iraq
which eventually becomes the islamic
state
of iraq and syria or isis a well-oiled
governmental and military organization
run by many of the military leaders who
were ousted by the americans from
the iraqi military when they took over
baghdad so iraq turns into the u.s
trying to fight this growing rebellion
billions of dollars turns into tens of
billions of dollars
and then hundreds of billions of dollars
and eventually crossing over
into over a trillion dollars of taxpayer
money
to fight this unnecessary war
saddam hussein was a really bad guy he
committed mass genocide against his own
people
the kurds he executed many others
imprisoned many others
all in all the number of dead on saddam
hussein's hands
numbers around 250 000 according to
human rights watch that was over 25
years of his brutal
regime and yet in just eight years of
this war that the u.s
started in iraq way more people were
killed a power vacuum was opened up that
allowed
isis to thrive and for what
why did we do this how was this worth it
i really believe that in the aftermath
of those towers
falling this group of guys began
constructing a story for themselves
a fantasy one not grounded in real facts
from intelligence but one grounded in
fear
and a desire to be the hero in the
messianic complex that
always infects the powerful that fantasy
trickled down
and spread to other people in power
leading us
into one of the most catastrophic and
unnecessary wars in modern history
[Music]
i challenge the president or whoever has
us here for 15 months
to ride along alongside me i'll do
another 15
months if he comes out here and rides
along with me every day for 15 months
[Music]
oof saddam hussein george bush
paul wolfowitz what a story what a story
um yeah anyway
i want to thank the sponsor of the video
today expressvpn
which is a service i've used for years
when i traveled i would use it
all the time to basically route my
connection through the united states so
i could not be like
kicked out of my gmail i don't travel
very much anymore so i use expressvpn
these days
to watch netflix specifically canadian
netflix
so basically with expressvpn it's not
only a security measure that helps you
secure your connection with encryption
and all this
great technology the reason i like it so
much is because i can route my
connection
through other countries and then netflix
thinks i'm in like the uk
or in canada and i can watch uk and
canadian
stuff that isn't available on netflix
the united states this is actually the
case with a lot of different streaming
services
i love expressvpn it's super easy it's
in like the menu bar
of my computer and all i have to do is
click it and decide the country
and boom i'm there like within a few
seconds oh and the best part is you can
get
three months of this literally for free
if you use the link in my description
it's expressvpn.com
johnny harris when you click that link
it helps support this channel but it
also gives you three months
literally free zero money to like use
this
thank you expressvpn for supporting this
channel
and thank you all for watching if you
want more middle east content
there is endless that's what i studied
in my undergrad was middle eastern
politics
and um there's just a lot so
i'm gonna get there i'm gonna get to the
rest of them if you all want it
because there is endless videos i could
make from the middle east
anyway have a good day see you